this is ea play live 2021
let's get to it
and now that the experts at codemasters
are joining the ea family
that incredible lineup just got
supercharged with the addition of
franchises like grid
dirt project cars and f1 joining us now
from london is codemaster's senior game
designer
becky crossdale on behalf of the entire
codemasters team
this is the world premiere trailer for
grid legends
yet we had the absolute pleasure of
working with the incredibly talented
shooti gagwa
who plays the wonderful eric in
netflix's sex education
we also captured the entire thing using
extended reality or
xr where if you've been watching
disney's and mandalorian you will have
seen that tech in action it's what they
used to create those
incredible worlds because they're acting
against something that's visually there
it's not the same as green screen or
motion capture
they are stepping into our grid world
and reacting with it
we are giving you a classic underdog
tale
we will put you straight into the
driver's seat right in the middle of the
grid world
series where you'll be facing off
against the all
dominant raven west team that is a team
that does not like to share the tarmac
because we are giving you big rigs
stadium trucks drift cars
open wheelers muscle cars electric cars
we are giving you hyper cars like the
aston martin
valkyrie and we are also giving you
multi-class
mixed racing which means that you can
take any of those cars and put them
together on the same track
there is a ton of new stuff for the fans
to sink their teeth
into including some new modes such as
boost mode and elimination mode we've
also got some fancy new locations like
the iconic city of moscow
we've also got the beautiful city of
london as well as you can drive right
past
buckingham palace or you could travel to
the stunning
strada alpena and take one of our
beautiful hyper cars
to its limit we've seen grid legends
and now it's time for a different breed
of legend
ladies and gentlemen i give to you apex
legends emergence
apex game director chad grenier similar
to bloodhound
seer is all about tracking enemies but
in a different way and has a very unique
kit
so while you're aiming down the sights
you'll have a heartbeat sensor that will
give you hints as to
where an enemy might be if you think
you've located them you can use your
tactical
which sends out some of those drones out
of your chest and will actually reveal
and track the enemy's location the
ultimate is really powerful especially
in certain gameplay situations you can
send out hundreds of micro drones
and create a sphere around an area that
you choose
and all enemies that are moving quickly
to that space are tracked
seer is about very precise and lingering
information
so he's a bit more of a stealth oriented
legend and you're going to see i think
some interactions because of that sphere
i mentioned his ultimate
if you're moving quickly through that
space your footsteps are revealed
but now if you're walking slowly you can
avoid the the detection
and so i think you'll see some
interesting gameplay experiences and new
ways to play
yeah with slowing it down a bit so we're
really excited in september to be
kicking off year two of the lgs
and for the first time we're going to be
inviting playstation
and xbox players to compete alongside
the pc players really see who's best
and an all new league format so um we
have more information
at playapex.com algs
and emergence drops on august 3rd and
for now
i can show you a finisher of course
please please
this game demands so much of us
but from you she demands
everything it was an official tribeca
film festival selection this summer and
it's coming soon
joining us from gothenburg sweden to
tell us more is zoink creative director
olav redmon hello austin how's it going
olaf thank you so much for joining us
and congratulations on tribeca
it's so cool to see video games right
next to movies being regarded as they
should be
thank you austin i'm so proud of the
song team and what we've accomplished
and
i'm so happy about this election because
lost in random is really inspired by all
these
movies that i grew up with and
stop-motion animation and dark fairy
tales and
and at sonic we're always trying to push
narrative in video games so i'm so happy
but what can you tell me about these
these combat cards that we're seeing
cars are just one part of dice battle
but i love the way they look so i
brought a few examples to show off
so as you saw cards can be selected
during combat that unleash new powers
and abilities like this one for instance
explosive dice which turns dicey into
this ticking time bomb
but you just gotta be careful so it
doesn't blow you up lost in random
releases on september 10th
on pc console and nintendo switch and
you can pre-order starting right after
the shows
that's right i'm talking about knock out
city oh oh oh okay
here with more is karthik bala from
velen studios in new york
thanks austin we're so grateful to our
community for the massive response to
knockout city
on behalf of the whole villain studios
team it's my absolute thrill to present
knockout city season two fight at the
movies
[Applause]
[Music]
the moment that you have been waiting
for is here
we're revealing a brand new battlefield
2042 experience
[Music]
let's bring on an expert here to help us
out is the general manager of ripple
effect we've got christian
grass so what you just saw was the
battlefield portal it's a new community
driven experience that gives
players the freedom to write their own
rules and shape their own battlefield
you can mix and match content from
battlefield 1942
back company 2 bf3 and battlefield 2042
to create brand new game modes then you
can share and discover those on the
portal platform
and that's just what's coming at launch
this is a real love letter to the fans
from our incredible team when you say
beloved maps we're talking caspian
border
yes eureka harbor yes
el alamein yes el alamein is also
included it's actually my all-time
favorite map
plus we have no shark canal battle of
the bulge
and valparaiso and of course
all seven of the new epic scale maps
already announced for 2042
they're also playable in portal portal
is a chance for the community to drive
the platform there's a whole slate
of customization options and even an
advanced logic editor for you to play
around with
tools that were previously only
available to us on the development team
and we're committed to working with the
community to build out this suite of
tools and content
as the game evolves we want this
experience to go where you want to take
it
we see this sandbox as a big part of the
future of battlefield 2042.
porter will be available at launch day
one
along with a bunch of pre-made modes for
you to try right away
so on top of all the content and maps
that have already been announced
we also get content from battlefield
1942
bad company 2 and battlefield 3
including six of the best maps of
all time and all that can be sliced
diced and mixed together in portal
and then we still have hazard zone
coming later this year
yes that's exactly what i'm telling you
austin if you've always been a fan
or if you've never played battlefield
before we want battlefield 2042 to be
the ultimate battlefield experience
i hope you've enjoyed the show as much
as i've enjoyed being your host
now my name is austin creed and our last
reveal is somewhere in
there but you know what
why don't you go first
okay
[Music]
you